they don't make plus size clothing because they don't want us to look good
I firmly believe that one of the reasons why plus size people do not have access
to cute clothing is because it would be much harder
to contribute to the myth that fat people are unattractive and ugly
and lazy and slobs and
like whatever
if we actually have clothes that fit us and make us look good
because so many people do not have access to cute plus size clothes
I spend a lot of time
a lot of money
and a lot of effort looking for clothing that I think is cool and fun
and unique and interesting
fits my body right
and that is a privilege that I am able to do
I'm able to have that privilege
that is not the case for every fat person
so a lot of the time
the clothing that the average fat person has access to is either a one of like
frumpy frocks that they give us
or it's like
slightly too small
and I don't care what size you are
I don't care if you're small or big
whatever like you
if the clothing is
like ill fitting
it's not going to look very good on
like obviously
I think you can pull it off
I know plenty of people that like
wears tighter clothes and looks perfect on them
but like generally speaking
if you're trying to like
fit your body into pants
that don't fit you
or clothes that don't fit you
that's not always the most
the most like
flattering thing
you know what I mean
like the muffin top that everyone is so afraid of
that happens because your pants are too small
so your stomach fat
like peeks over
and when you're wearing pants that fit your body
that doesn't happen
so then we get this like
stereotype of fat people like
stealing small people's clothing and like
always squeezing into sizes that are too small
and da da da
and it's like
they we do that
people do that because they don't have access to clothing in their size
you understand
and I just don't think that you're able to like
maximize your slay
if you're trying to constantly find clothes that you can squeeze into
instead of just by being able to buy clothes in your size
and we can have a conversation about
the politics of flattering clothes another time
but the reality is
when fat people wear clothes that aren't flattering
it automatically like
deems us as ugly to people
but again that's a lot of people's only choice if they want like
trendy stylish clothes
and like for me
it's on issue
because I am
like on the like
the larger end of the plus size spectrum
so I don't even have the option
really to like
squeeze into tighter clothes
but I understand if you're like
on the smaller end of the spectrum
if you're like a 1416
and you really wanna wear this one item of clothing and
like you know
it's a size 12
you wanna squeeze into it like
I understand that
you know what I mean
it's just like not fair
it's not fair that you have to do that and like
if we don't wanna do that
the other option is like
have you been to a target section for plus sizes
like they have wild and fable
I shop a lot of dresses from like
wild and fable
which is like
their regular
kind of youth ish line
um and online
they go to a 4X
and I look really good in those clothes I love them
but all of those plus sizes are not available in store
the plus sizes that are available in store are Ava and Viv
and Ava and Viv is just
literally like
cottage core but like
derogatory actually
you know what it is
it's Little House in the Prairie core
it's like shirts up to here
dresses up to here
like frilly big boxy
like no shape
it's it's I hate it
do they relegate fat people to like
either squeezing into tight
fashionable clothing
and it looking ill fitting on us
or wearing clothing that's in our size
and it's just like
not flattering
it's like from the 18th century
and it doesn't look good
no one wants to wear it
and so obviously
perpetuates this kind of myth that
like fat people
can't dress fat people like
can't look cool
they can't look stylish
and it's like
you're not giving us the option to
and personally
I think that
some of the most fashion people I've ever seen in my life
are plus size
because we have to do that work to like
put in that extra effort
to look stylish if
if you wanna do that
as a fat person
but it's just not fair that
that's what we have to do
and I truly genuinely
believe that
at least a small reason
why the fashion industry
doesn't make
plus size clothing
that is cool and fashionable
cause like literally
all you have to do is
make it into plus
I make the straight sizes
plus size all you have to do
and the reason they don't do that (my theory at least) is because then
they can't say
that fat people don't look good
cause like we do
like when fat people wear cool clothing
like first of all
you're more like
you're more attractive
because you're more confident
I think that's a big thing
sorry I'm literally just ranting
but growing up like
there's a period of time where
all I really shopped at was macy's and Walmart
because that was kind of
the only place that I found clothes that fit me
but obviously like
the clothes weren't cute
especially back
in like 2000
you know 12 13
14 whatever like
it was old woman clothes
it was hideous
hideous like
obviously I was gonna get bullied
and the moment I found
torrid and like
say what you want about it now
but for me in
like high school
torrid was like
torrid was it
that was the first time
that I had seen clothes that were even like
mildly trendy in my size
and I have such a vivid memory
of going into the torrid dressing rooms
for the first time
and finding a
bra that fit me
and it wasn't like
a sports bra
it was like an actual bra with cups
and it was blue
and black pattern
and I cried in the dressing room
I cried positive
for the first time in my life
in a dressing room
because I was like
oh my god like
this fits me
and it's cute
it was genuinely
one of those experiences that I
it's a flashable memory
I I to this day
remember how I felt
when that happened
and literally
like my entire
like attitude
shifted after that
like because
I started wearing
clothes that fit me well
and that were cool and like
I had autonomy
and it genuinely
made such an
impact on the
way that I felt
about myself
and that was then
and obviously like
things have changed
in the fat fashion world
but I just know for me
how important
my fashion is
to my confidence
and just how attractive
I think that I am
in my opinion
generally the right outfit
is the difference
between like
a 5 and a 10
like I'm BI but
I'm not attracted to one
like physical attribute
I literally am
attracted to
people that like
wear black and like
wear alternative clothing and like
the style that
like the style
that people wear
genuinely will make me
attracted like
that's besides the point
style and fashion
is so important
and I think that
letting fat people have
autonomy and like
have the choice
to look cool
and look fashionable
and dressed the
way they want
is so revolutionary
and the fact
that we're walking it back now
is not lost on me
and I just like
cause that's
the only thing
that makes sense to me
because what other
reason would
the fashion industry have
do not cater to
plus size people
considering that 67%
like two thirds
of this country
is plus size and like
we are only like
20% of the market
if that anyways
this has been long enough
I can talk about this for
literally ages
but the fashion industry
just doesn't want fat
people to reach their full potential
and I am 100%
certain of that